Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. Today's episode of The Rest Is History on treason in medieval and Tudor England
感谢您收听《一切皆历史》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告畅听、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢您收听《一切皆历史》。想要收听独家节目、抢先体验、无广告畅听并访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在 App 内订阅。今天这期关于中世纪和都铎王朝时期叛国罪的《一切皆历史》节目
is sponsored by the National Archives. Enjoy the show. Hello and welcome to The Rest Is History and Dominic. This has been a month absolutely full of news, has it not? I mean, one could say there's been an excess of news. You can never have too much news, has it not? I mean, one could say there's been an excess of news. You can never have too much news, Tom. Well, so, I don't know if you saw a few weeks back, in the Sunday Times, one of the many papers for which you write. Of course, I must have read every word. Well, so did you notice this?
由国家档案馆赞助。节目开始。大家好，欢迎来到《一切皆历史》，我是多米尼克。这个月的新闻可真是铺天盖地，不是吗？我的意思是，可以说新闻有点过剩了。新闻可永远嫌不多，对吧？我的意思是，可以说新闻有点过剩了。新闻可永远嫌不多，汤姆。好吧，那么，我不知道你几周前有没有看《星期日泰晤士报》，这是你经常供稿的众多报纸之一。我当然每个字都读了。好吧，那你注意到这个了吗？
That there was a report about the treason laws. And it said, ministers are planning to, amid all the other things they're planning, ministers are planning to update all the other things they're planning. Ministers are planning to update Britain's 650 year old treason laws so they can be used to prosecute jihadis, hackers and other malign actors who swear allegiance to a hostile foreign power. You will recall that I was described as a malign actor by the Scotsman at the Edinburgh Festival for my as thomas beckett a man who himself had his issues with the monarchy well it would be very exciting if bad acting could be included in the remit of the treason marilyn monroe impersonation i guess that what they're talking about there is particularly i mean the notorious case is shamima begum isn't
关于叛国罪的一篇报道。报道称，大臣们正计划在他们筹划的其他所有事情之中，大臣们正计划更新——在他们筹划的其他所有事情之中，大臣们正计划更新英国拥有 650 年历史的叛国罪法律，以便能够用它来起诉效忠于敌对外国势力的圣战分子、黑客和其他恶意分子。你可能还记得，我在爱丁堡艺术节上被《苏格兰人报》描述为一个“恶意分子”，因为我扮演了托马斯·贝克特，一个本身与君主制有过节的人。好吧，如果恶劣表演能被纳入叛国罪的管辖范围，那将非常令人兴奋。玛丽莲·梦露模仿秀，我想他们在那儿讨论的特别是指——我的意思是，臭名昭著的案子是沙米玛·贝古姆，对吧？
it the um the girl who uh went out from london to uh become a jihadi bride um and the ISIS Beatles, again, the people from Britain who went out, pledged allegiance to the Islamic State, burned their passports, all that kind of stuff. And the difficulty of applying the treason law. But I guess the thing that really stands out maybe for lots of people is that there is a treason law and that it is 650 years old. It's a good story, isn't it? Now, people may have noticed, Tom the unusual the extraordinary charge the intimacy i think the intimacy of our opening banter that we're actually in the same room for months gazing into each other's eyes it's
那个从伦敦出发去当圣战新娘的女孩，还有“伊斯兰国”披头士乐队，同样是那些来自英国、前往并宣誓效忠“伊斯兰国”、烧掉护照等等的人。以及适用叛国罪的困难。但我想对许多人来说，真正突出的地方在于竟然有一部叛国罪法，而且它已经有 650 年的历史了。这是一个好故事，不是吗？现在，大家可能已经注意到了，汤姆，不同寻常的、非同寻常的指控，这种亲密感——我认为我们开场闲聊的这种亲密感，是因为我们实际上几个月来一直在同一个房间里凝视彼此的眼睛，这
incredibly moving you have to be here really um we are at the national archives aren't we tom and does it have anything to do with treason dominic it does It does. Let me just say this. Tom, have you been to the National Archives before as a top historian? I've never been. Never been. So, Tom, this is a very exciting and moving moment.
实在太感人了。你真的必须亲自来这里，嗯……我们现在在国家档案馆，对吧，汤姆？这和叛国罪有什么关系吗，多米尼克？有的，有的。我先说这个。汤姆，你以前作为顶级历史学家来过国家档案馆吗？我从来没来过。从来没来过。所以，汤姆，这是一个非常令人兴奋和感动的时刻。
So we're at the National Archives and they have an amazing new exhibition that is starting this autumn and it's all about... On the 5th of November, I think. All about treason. So we thought we would come along...
我们现在在国家档案馆，他们有一个将于今秋开幕的精彩全新展览，主题全部关于……我想是在 11 月 5 日。全部关于叛国罪。所以我们想来看看……
The perfect start, the 5th of November. There you go. So we thought we would come along 5th of november there you go so we thought we would come along guy falk style have a little look um and tom we are very very fortunate because we are joined by an absolute top treason expert one of the men behind the exhibition it is of course you and roger you and thank you so much for joining us on The Rest Is History. Hi. It's a great pleasure to have you on the show. So is this something that you've always been into? Have you always had a sort of treacherous heart?
完美的开端，11 月 5 日。就是这样。所以我们想在 11 月 5 日那天来看看，就是这样，所以我们想来模仿盖伊·福克斯的风格，随便看看。嗯，汤姆，我们非常非常幸运，因为我们迎来了一位绝对顶级的叛国罪专家，也是展览幕后的策划人之一，他就是尤恩·罗杰。尤恩，非常感谢你来到《一切皆历史》做客。嗨。很高兴你能来节目。所以，这是你一直以来就很感兴趣的领域吗？你一直都有一种叛逆的心吗？
It's, I think, treason legislation and the Treason Act and this treason exhibition that we've been working on, it really brings in so many different things about medieval modern history. I think it's almost impossible not to be fascinated by some of the subjects that it covers yeah and so uh yeah it's been just exciting to try and dig into some of these stories and and tell that long long history so tom you did in characteristic tom holland fashion i know you've done loads of preparation on roman treason which sadly which sadly we won't have time for today.
我认为，叛国罪立法、《叛国罪法案》以及我们一直在筹备的这个叛国罪展览，它实际上涵盖了中世纪和现代历史的诸多不同方面。我想几乎不可能不被它所涉及的一些主题所吸引。所以，是的，能够深入挖掘其中一些故事并讲述那段漫长的历史，真的非常令人兴奋。因此，汤姆，你以典型的汤姆·霍兰德方式——我知道你对罗马叛国罪做了大量准备，虽然遗憾的是——我们今天没有时间详谈了。
Maybe we'll come to it in some elliptical manner. But the idea of treason has obviously been, treason has been a crime that's different from other crimes. That's been around for a long time, right? Yeah, so concepts of treason have been around for a really, really long time. In England, it's Alfred the Great that we really start to see what we might think of as high treason, distinguishing the crown
也许我们会以某种曲折的方式谈到它。但叛国罪的概念显然一直是……叛国罪一直是一种不同于其他犯罪的罪行。它已经存在很长时间了，对吧？是的，所以叛国罪的概念存在的时间非常非常长。在英国，我们真正开始看到我们可以认为是“谋反罪”萌芽的是在阿尔弗雷德大帝时期，它将王室
from the nobility. But concepts of treason have been around forever, really. That idea of betrayal, that idea of someone letting you down or levying war against you or plotting your death, it really has been around for a very long time. Could I just very briefly mention the Romans? And he was going to. So they had this idea of maestestas as lace majesty the the idea that you
与贵族区分开来。但叛国罪的概念其实一直都存在。背叛的概念，某人让你失望、对你发动战争或密谋杀死你的想法，确实存在了很长时间。我能简短地提一下罗马人吗？他正准备提呢。所以他们有“大不敬罪”（maestestas）的概念——对罗马人民威严的犯罪的概念，这
commit an offense against the majesty of the roman people and that's something that exists under the republican system of government but then when the um when the caesars come to power it starts to be applied by individual emperors to take out their enemies and so an idea that you can commit treason against the state starts to narrow down and become the idea that you commit treason against an individual ruler but in england and then ultimately britain it's the other way around isn't it you over the span of the the centuries this 650 years that the treason act has been in existence to begin with it's very focused on the figure of the monarch. And now we would understand treason as being something
在共和政体下就存在。但后来当凯撒大帝掌权时，它开始被各个皇帝用来铲除政敌。因此，“可以背叛国家”的概念开始缩小，变成“可以背叛单个统治者”的概念。但在英国，最终在英国本土，情况正好相反，不是吗？在跨越几个世纪的时间里——即《叛国罪法案》存在的这 650 年里——一开始，它非常专注于君主的个人形象。而现在，我们会将叛国罪理解为一种
that is targeted against the whole country, against all the people within the country. Do you think that would be a kind of fair way of putting it? Yeah, so one of the things I think we've drawn out by doing such a long history in one exhibition is how these ideas change and develop over time. Because as you say, ideas from the Roman system like Lesser Majesté don't really get picked up as much in England as they do in, say, France,
针对整个国家、针对国内所有人民的目标。你觉得这样说算是一个比较公平的说法吗？是的，所以通过在一个展览中呈现如此漫长的历史，我们所展现出来的其中一点就是这些理念随时间推移是如何改变和发展的。因为正如你所说，来自罗马体系的“大不敬罪”之类的概念并没有像在比如法国那样在英国得到那么广泛的采纳，
where it becomes a much more central part of the system. But in England, particularly in the period up to the 14th century, it's really undefined. And then we start to see this development first against the crown and then moving into treason against the state. So could we could we look at how the the the act that comes in in 1351, the backstory to that? And basically it's all about kings called Edward, isn't it? So Edward I, very popular with the Welsh, very popular with the Scots. But it's in Wales that the kind of the form of punishment that I guess most people would associate with treason, hanging, drawing and quartering is kind of made emblematic. And Edward I is fighting against the Welsh.
在法国，它成为了体系中更为核心的一部分。但在英国，特别是在 14 世纪之前的时期，它其实并未得到明确定义。然后我们开始看到这种发展：首先是针对君主，然后演变为针对国家的叛国罪。那么，我们能否探讨一下 1351 年颁布的法案及其背后的故事呢？基本上这全都是关于名叫爱德华的国王，对吧？比如爱德华一世，对威尔士人很受欢迎，对苏格兰人很受欢迎。但在威尔士，大多数人可能将叛国罪与那种刑罚联系在一起——绞刑、剖腹并分尸——这种刑罚形式开始具有标志性意义，当时爱德华一世正在与威尔士作战。
And there is a Welsh prince who basically, as Edward sees it, betrays him. And could you just tell us about him and the terrible fate that is visited on him? So Edward I is very much, uses treason in a very personal way, I would say. He's very, he's offended by the Welsh princes fighting back against him. He's offended by the Scots on the northern border. And with Daffod Ap Griffith, he very much makes this a symbolic act. So they specifically link specific crimes to actions. So drawing out of entrails is very much linked to specific acts.
并且有一个威尔士亲王，在爱德华看来，他背叛了他。你能给我们讲讲他以及降临在他身上的可怕命运吗？所以爱德华一世非常倾向于以非常个人化的方式使用叛国罪，我会这么说。他对威尔士亲王的反抗感到被冒犯，对北部边境的苏格兰人感到被冒犯。对于达菲德·阿普·格里菲思（Daffod Ap Griffith），他非常明确地将其变成了一种象征性的行为。因此，他们将特定的罪行与具体的行动明确联系起来。比如掏出内脏就与特定的行为密切相关。
Hanging someone, drawing them. Drawing is actually the most emblematic punishment associated with treason, being so what's it what's it symbolizing it's in a way i guess it's a form of um taking someone down or embarrassment's the wrong word but making someone suffer a very visible punishment they're drawn at a horse's tail through the town or through the city to the place of execution and some people were practically half dead by the time they got to the actual the actual point of execution and the hanging is that is that you're kind of lifting them up from the they're no longer allowed
把人绞死，然后拖行。拖行实际上是与叛国罪联系最紧密的标志性刑罚，所以……这象征着什么？在某种程度上，我想这是一种……让人倒台的方式，或者说“尴尬”这个词不太恰当，而是让某人遭受非常显眼的惩罚。他们被绑在马尾巴后面，穿过城镇或城市，一直拖到行刑地点。有些人到达实际行刑地点时，基本上已经半死不活了。而绞刑则是……你是把他们从……他们不再被允许
to keep their feet on on the on the earth on the soil of the country spectacular hanging is spectacular a huge crowd can see it right in a way they might not be able to but if there's a symbolism to it as well yeah of course and. And presumably the castration element as well, you're extirpating the entire line. So the castration, is that drawing? Is that part of the drawing phase or the quartering phase? So the drawing is actually the physical being drawn by a horse's tail. It's not that disemboweling process.
把双脚踩在大地上，踩在这个国家的土地上。这种绞刑非常壮观，一大群人可以亲眼看到，这是他们可能无法通过其他方式看到的。但其中也有象征意义，对吧？当然有。而且推测还有阉割的成分，你要斩除整个血统。所以阉割，那是拖行的一部分，还是分尸阶段的一部分？所以拖行实际上是指被马尾巴物理拖拽的物理过程。这并不是指取出内脏的过程。
Okay. That is often part of it. That's often part of the punishment that is brought out, but that's not the drawing as such. They've almost been conflated over the years, but the, the hanging element is, is visible.
好的。这通常是其中的一部分。这通常是被拿出来说的刑罚的一部分，但那本身并不是拖行。多年来它们几乎被混为一谈了，但是绞刑的部分是清晰可见的。
We know in some instances for Edward, the second train, for example, that Hugh Spencer, the younger gets seemingly hanged on a huge, huge set of scaffolds so that people can see this is visible, this is public. But they're not allowed to die at that point.
我们知道在爱德华二世统治的一些例子中，例如年幼的小休·德斯潘塞，似乎被绞死在一个巨大无比的脚手架上，以便人们能够看到——这是清晰可见的，这是公开的。但当时并不允许他们直接死去。
They're then brought down, often disemboweled, sometimes castrated, but not always. And then finally they're... Ported. So that the four parts, they're cut into four, right? Yeah, so they'd have their heads chopped off first and then the four parts. But again, is there a kind of symbolism that you as a traitor have aspired to remove the head of the kingdom? So your head is removed and you have aspired to divide the kingdom. So you yourself are divided. Is that kind of the idea that lies behind it?
他们随后被放下来，通常会被开膛破肚，有时会被阉割，但并非总是如此。最后他们被……分尸。所以这四个部分，他们被切成四块，对吧？是的，所以他们会先被砍头，然后分成四部分。但同样地，这里面是不是有一种象征意义：作为一个叛国者，你曾企图砍掉国家的头颅？所以你的头被砍掉了，而你曾企图分裂国家。所以你自己也被分裂了。这是否就是背后的某种理念？
So it's difficult to tell with all of this because none of the legislation actually such actually defines this in the medieval period this is custom it's custom it's brought out in law law codes but it's never really defined particularly while treason is undefined prior to the 14th century and but in terms of the quartering that is again very much this visible spectacle because these quarters are sent to yeah right york norwich bristol wherever and they're often linked to places where an individual had committed deeds or places that might be fermenting and we actually have one example of payments being made to make sure that these quarters were preserved and got to their intended locations without rotting in the process so we know that they are being sent to these places,
所以要弄清楚所有这些是很困难的，因为在中世纪，所有这些立法实际上都没有对此进行真正定义。这是习惯，这是习惯。它在法律法典中被提及，但从未真正得到明确定义，特别是在 14 世纪之前叛国罪一直未被明确定义的时候。但是就分尸而言，这同样是一个非常明显的视觉奇观，因为这些尸块被送到——是的，没错，约克、诺维奇、布里斯托尔或任何地方——它们通常与某个人犯下罪行的地点，或是可能正在酝酿叛乱的地点联系在一起。我们实际上有一个支付费用的记录，以确保这些尸块在运送过程中没有腐烂，并安全送达预定地点。所以我们知道它们被运到了这些地方，
and they are being exhibited, and they don't want them to... They're like in a barrel of wine or something like that, are they? It's a lot of salt, I think. Salt and lots of wrapping is the key element. I'd volunteer for that job if you're going to do a medieval job. Law and order. Yeah, I'm very much about social stability. Yes. So talking of social stability, let's move on towards some of the documents. I know, Tom, you love the quartering but we have to we have to talk about some of the
并且它们被展示出来，人们不希望它们……它们是被泡在酒桶里之类的吗？我想主要是用了大量的盐。盐和大量的包裹是关键要素。如果你要干中世纪的活，我自愿承担这份工作。法律与秩序。是的，我非常主张社会稳定。是的。说到社会稳定，让我们继续讨论一些文件。我知道，汤姆，你很喜欢分尸，但我们不得不、我们不得不讨论一些
the proper the historical stuff because you have the most amazing selection of so of documents you start with the treason act so the road to the treason act how do we get there like what why do people feel they need it so under ebba the first we very much get treason being used as a charge against the king's enemies whether well in wales or are they going to trial are they being tried so this is a very interesting question because edward i's prosecution of these people is often relies on what's called the king's record so in medieval, you're not supposed to be accuser and sentencer in the same moment. So Edward I comes up with this elaborate concept where essentially he presents evidence to, say, parliament, for example, and they are required to say whether these instances are classed as treason. Are they treasonous?
正经的历史资料，因为你们拥有最令人惊叹的文件选择。你们从《叛国罪法案》开始讲起——通往《叛国罪法案》之路，我们是如何走到这一步的？为什么人们觉得需要它？所以在爱德华一世统治下，我们非常明显地看到叛国罪被用作指控国王敌人的罪名，无论是在威尔士还是苏格兰……他们是在受审吗？他们是否正接受审判？这是一个非常有趣的问题，因为爱德华一世对这些人的起诉通常依赖于所谓的“国王记录”。在中世纪，
When they say that they are, the king takes that as this evidence being presented to him by his nobles and his justices can then proceed to sentencing. And that is different from bills of attainder, which you mentioned the dispensers, who are not things you get soft drinks from. They are powerful noblemen in the reign of Edward II, father and son son and they get tainted don't they and that's kind of um slightly different
你不应该同时成为起诉人和判决人。因此，爱德华一世想出了这样一个精心设计的概念：本质上，他向议会等机构提交证据，并要求他们说明这些案件是否属于叛国罪。它们是否构成叛国？
that namely the king can basically say i'm bringing in a specific bill of attainder against against you hugh dispenser the elder hugh dispenser the younger and they get killed except in this case it's complicated because it's actually the king's enemies who are doing it. Yeah, so I'd say it's a dual concept. Edward II's reign is a bit of a nightmare for treason because you get, on one hand, the king's record. On the other hand, this attainting process, which is probably just briefly say what attainting means. It's literally to do with a taint on someone's bloodline. So the main way that treason is different from any other crime, murder for example, is that nobles, estates and goods are forfeited to the crown indefinitely.
当他们给出肯定答复时，国王便将此视为贵族和法官向他提交的证据，随后便可进入量刑程序。这与“剥夺公权法案”（bills of attainder）不同——你刚才提到了德斯潘塞父子，他们可不是那种能买到软饮料的地方。他们是爱德华二世统治时期的权贵父子，他们被剥夺了政治权利，对吧？这有点……略有不同，
Their heirs cannot inherit. So the crime of the father is inherited by the sons and grandsons or whatever. Yes, very much so. And that's what makes treason, at a moment where you're talking about nobility and the crown that is a powerful tool and what you see in edward ii's reign is factionalism favorites
也就是说，国王基本上可以宣布：“我针对老休·德斯潘塞和小休·德斯潘塞提出具体的剥夺公权法案。”然后他们就被处决了。只不过在这个案例中情况比较复杂，因为实际上是国王的政敌在这么做。是的，所以我认为这是一个双重概念。爱德华二世的统治对叛国罪来说简直是一场噩梦，因为一方面你会得到“国王记录”，另一方面则是这种剥夺公权的程序。也许你可以简要说明一下“剥夺公权”（attainting）是什么意思。它字面意思是给某人的血统留下污点。所以叛国罪与其他任何罪行（比如谋杀）最主要的区别在于，贵族的地产和财产被无限期地没收给王室。
utilizing these charges whoever's got the king's ear can use this this charge this accusation against their enemies and it becomes a powerful way of wiping out entire bloodlines if you have the king's ear, if you have power. And that's really where I think the Treason Act comes from because if you can charge anyone with treason, it doesn't really have a meaning anymore. And so that's where, under Edward III's rule, we see an attempt to try and redraw that boundary in the sand to say this is acceptable, but this is not
他们的继承人无法继承。因此，父亲的罪行由儿子、孙子等人承袭。是的，确实如此。这就是为什么在涉及贵族和王室的时期，叛国罪是一个强有力的工具。你在爱德华二世的统治中看到的是派系斗争、权臣宠臣利用这些指控。任何能够左右国王心意的人都可以利用这个指控、这个罪名来对付他们的政敌。如果你能左右国王、拥有权力，这就成了铲除整个家族血统的有力手段。这也就是我认为《叛国罪法案》真正诞生的原因，因为如果你可以指控任何人犯有叛国罪，那么这个罪名就彻底失去了意义。因此，在爱德华三世的统治下，我们看到了试图重新划定界限的尝试，以表明哪些是可接受的，而哪些是不可接受的。
acceptable. Okay, so that's how we get to the Bill of 1351. So you've got in front of you the text, have you, of the original, this is the original text of the Treason Act, basically. Yeah, so what we've got here, and this is very much the heart of our exhibition, I should say very briefly, we are actually using the date 1352 for the act of this. And that's because under medieval concepts of time, they didn't use December as the end of the year. Yeah, of course. So for the medieval people, this would have taken place in 1351. But in modern historical thought, we use 1352.
可以接受。好的，这就是我们如何追溯到1351年法令。所以你们面前摆着的是……没错，这是原件的文本，基本上这就是《叛国法》的原件。是的，我们这里拥有的，这也是我们展览的核心，我简短地说明一下，我们实际上采用1352年作为该法令生效的年份。这是因为在中世纪的时间观念下，他们并不把十二月当作一年的结束。是的，当然。所以对于中世纪的人来说，这发生在1351年。但在现代历史学中，我们使用的是1352年。
And it's very complicated because lawyers use 1351 and historians use 1352 and at the national archives obviously we have the historical documents and we tend to use the the modern historical dating but we also have a function of as the as what's called legislation.gov so publishing legislation and because that's legal thought that uses 1351 so let's just say the early 1350s um so so what what does it specify what can you be basically what can you be done for uh as a traitor so what we have here is we have the treason act and we have actually got two copies we've got the parliament royal copy which is the kind of precursor and what this has is the nobles actually asking the king to define
这非常复杂，因为法律界使用1351年，而历史学家使用1352年。在国家档案馆，我们显然拥有历史文献，所以我们倾向于使用现代历史纪年，但我们同时也承担着类似legislation.gov这样的职能，即发布立法。由于那是法律界思维，它使用的是1351年。所以，我们姑且称之为14世纪50年代早期……那么，它具体规定了什么？基本上，你做什么事会被当作叛国者治罪？这里有《叛国法》，实际上我们有两个副本。我们有英王御前国会卷轴，可以看作是它的前身。这里记录的是贵族们请求国王明确
what treason is so it's not just coming from the king it's coming from a request is the nobles actually asking the king to define what treason is so it's not just coming from the king it's coming from a request from his nobles and obviously for people who can't see it i mean it literally is a role i mean it's a role of parchment this is presumably written on with um do you know what the ink would be gall ink i am gall ink probably and it's written in french in anglo-norman french yeah and so we have the Parliament roll in our exhibition, which is just amazing. We've got the actual first statute roll. So when we talk about legislation today going on the statute book, we have the medieval version, literally.
叛国是什么。所以这不仅仅来自国王的意愿，而是来自贵族们的请求。对于看不到实物的人来说，它实际上就是一个卷轴，一张羊皮纸卷。上面写着的墨水，你们知道会是什么墨水吗？没食子墨水，我猜很可能是没食子墨水。它是用法语写的，盎格鲁-诺曼法语。因此，我们的展览中展出了国会卷轴，这简直太棒了。我们拥有第一份真正的法规卷轴。所以当我们今天谈论立法被收入法规汇编时，这就是它的中世纪版本，字面意义上的版本。
And it's got so much important legislation on it that it very rarely comes out. So it's just amazing to have it in the exhibition. It's very much the heart of everything, this entire story that we're going through so as i understand it there are six six six terms is that right um so attempting to kill or even imagining the death of the king queen or elders male heir to the throne yes but that's i mean even imagining it that's how the eighth uses that doesn't it yeah so the term is compassing and imagining which is a very broad term and it gets it gets radically reinterpreted as time goes on and each time you set a new precedent and that is still on the statute book yes okay and the second one also violating the king's companion his eldest unmarried daughter or the eldest male heir's wife
上面有如此多重要的立法，以至于它极少拿出来展出。因此，能在展览中展出它真的太棒了。它几乎是一切的核心，是我们正在探讨的整个故事的核心。据我所知，这里有六条条款，对吗？嗯……比如企图谋杀或甚至图谋杀害国王、王位继承人（即国王、王后或长子）？是的，但“图谋”这个词——甚至只是心生谋害之意——亨利八世就是这么用的，对吧？是的，所以这个术语是“谋划与图谋”（compassing and imagining），这是一个非常广泛的术语。随着时间的推移，它被进行了激进的重新解释，每次都会确立一个新的先例。而这在法规汇编中依然存在。是的。好的，第二条也是：强奸国王的伴侣、国王的长未婚女或长男继承人的妻子。
that's still on the statute book it is so what does that mean uh violating does that mean raping or so what it's an attempt essentially to preserve the royal bloodline it's to avoid any any external influence on that line so yeah it's very much about preserving the inheritance now i should say that that clause is still in modern legislation, but it was actually updated in 2015 to make it gender neutral, because obviously succession to the Crown Act was brought in. But what does violating mean? I mean, does it mean... Well, if it's your imagination, Tom. So, I guess it depends on how you would interpret medieval language, and people have been doing that throughout the centuries since 1352.
这依然保留在法规汇编中。确实如此。那么这代表什么意思？“强奸”是指强奸还是……本质上，这是为了保护王室血统，为了避免任何外部势力对该血统的影响。所以是的，这主要是为了保护继承权。顺便说一句，这一条款在现代立法中仍然存在，但它在2015年进行了更新，使其变为性别中立，因为当时出台了《王位继承法》。但“强奸”究竟是什么意思？我是说，这难道是指……好吧，如果全凭想象的话，汤姆。所以，我想这取决于你如何解读中世纪的语言，而自1352年以来的几个世纪里，人们一直在这样做。
Many fees for the barristers there. Yeah. Beyond the monarch, it talks about what's called levying war. Now this is a really interesting concept because levying war, this is a time when we're talking about the crown and nobles. So we're talking about
大律师们可以赚取大笔咨询费了。除了君主之外，它还谈到了所谓的“发动战争”。这是一个非常有趣的 концепт（概念），因为在谈到发动战争时，我们指的是国王与贵族之间。所以我们谈论的是
unfurling banners in battlefield in open war. Actually, when we get to the later 14th century, the crown and the justice get into a right mess about all of because the Peasants' Revolt of 1381, they think this is treasonous. But actually, it's not levying war as in the way that it was defined in statute. And so they try and prosecute the peasants under this term, but they can't really. They can't make it stick, basically.
在战场上公开战争中展开旗帜。事实上，到了14世纪后期，国王和司法官员对这一切陷入了一团糟，因为1381年的农民起义爆发了，他们认为这是叛国行为。但实际上，这并不是法规中所定义的那种“发动战争”。因此，他们试图以这个罪名起诉农民，但实际上做不到。基本上，他们无法将罪名定实。
Yeah, in some cases, they try and make it stick. But it's a reinterpretation of this and is that the statute book yes that is okay so living war against the crown in his realm that's that's that's bad um adhering to the king's enemies in his own realm or elsewhere i mean that's what i guess the isis people have been doing so it's an interesting um one about how is being written, because at this time as well, a lot of the king's nobles and the king himself claim lands in France. So there's a very technical terminology being used here in order that if the king went to war as a noble with another noble in France, that that wouldn't be treasonous because it's not in the realm. The interpretation of that has evolved over time. So if you're broadcasting for the Nazis or running off to sign up to the caliphate, presumably those terms would still apply, would they?
是的，在某些情况下，他们试图定罪。但这是对这一条款的重新解释，而这依然在法规汇编里？是的，还在。好的，所以：在国王的领土内对国王及其王国发动战争，这……这很糟糕。呃……在国王的领土内或境外依附国王的敌人。我想这正是伊斯兰国（ISIS）那些人一直在做的事。所以这是一个有趣的例子，关于法律是如何被书写的。因为在那个时期，许多国王的贵族以及国王本人在法国都拥有领地。这里使用了非常技术性的术语，以便如果国王作为贵族与法国的另一个贵族交战，那将不被视为叛国，因为它不在本国领土内。这一解释随时间而演变。所以，如果你为纳粹广播，或者跑去加入哈里发国，想必这些条款仍然适用，对吗？
It's very, I mean, this originally... That's still on the statute book, is it? Yes, this is on the statute book today. But all of this is an interpretation of the Anglo-Norman French. So we've always got to be careful about how we examine these things. And there's a whole load of more clauses that have now been removed. So those are the key clauses. But there's also concerns about counterfeiting.
这非常……我是说，这最初……这仍然在法规汇编中吗？是的，今天这依然在法规汇编里。但所有这些都是对盎格鲁-诺曼法语的解读。所以我们在审视这些事情时必须时刻谨慎。还有一大堆现在已经被移除的条款。所以这些是核心条款。但同时也涉及伪造货币的问题。
But they go very specific on the counterfeiting. It's specific money from Luxembourg that's been brought into the kingdom. You want to watch out for that, Luxembourg. What a shame that's been removed. As someone who was born in Luxembourg, I can't say anything on that. They surely use the euro in Luxembourg now, do they? They do, yes. So would that count as treasonous?
但他们在伪造货币方面非常具体。具体指的是从卢森堡带入王国的特定货币。你可得当心卢森堡。真可惜这一条被删除了。作为在卢森堡出生的人，我对此无可奉告。他们在卢森堡现在肯定用欧元了吧？是的，用的。那么这会被算作叛国吗？
No, so this has all been taken out of the legislation. I've spent far too long writing for Britain's most popular newspaper, Tom, clearly. So this comes in under the reign of Edward III. And Edward III is a triumphant king, but then is succeeded by Richard II, who is a more histrionically autocratic figure, isn't he? Yeah, you see, under Edward III, you see a very strong relationship
不，所以这些都已经从立法中删除了。汤姆，我显然花在为全英国最受欢迎的报纸写稿的时间太长了。所以，这一切发生在爱德华三世统治时期。爱德华三世是一位凯旋的国王，但随后继位的是理查二世，他是一个更具戏剧性、更专制的统治者，不是吗？是的，你看，在爱德华三世统治下，你可以看到非常紧密的关系
between the crown and the nobles. Under Richard II, that is very much not the case, because the king is a child when he takes the throne and you see a lot of factionalism returning um and we've kind of talk about that more in the exhibition we've actually got inventories of some of the goods that the favorites are forfeiting um including this lovely bed cover which is embroidered with butterflies and that's the um that's one of the king's nobles has got this butterfly a bed set but but richard ii ends up deposed by his cousin who becomes henry bollenbrook who becomes henry the fourth i mean toppling a king an anointed king that's the definition of treason isn't it
在国王和贵族之间。但在理查二世统治下，情况绝对不是这样的，因为国王登基时还是个孩子，你又看到了许多派系争斗卷土重来。我们在展览中更详细地谈到了这一点。我们实际上有那些失宠者被没收的部分财产清单，包括这张绣着蝴蝶的精美床罩。那是国王的一位贵族拥有的蝴蝶床品套件。但是……理查二世最终被他的堂弟废黜，后者成为了亨利·博林布鲁克，也就是亨利四世。推翻一位国王，一位受过涂油礼的国王，这就是叛国的定义，对吧？
so henry the fourth is a traitor presumably so this is a very interesting question because when parliament are considering all of this and when the nobility are considering all of this around richard's deposition they get almost the way there but they they force them to they depose him first they but they force him to abdicate willingly um in quotations i would say so it's very much they they don't take that final step and one of the really interesting things we've seen putting this exhibition together is that process by which in the 17th century they will take that final step. But under Richard II, Parliament's not quite powerful enough to do it. They're sort of inhibited from doing it, basically. the fourth and Henry the fifth, if people are rushing around saying, actually, you're usurpers,
所以亨利四世大概是个叛国者。这是一个非常有趣的问题，因为当议会审议这一切、当贵族们在理查被废黜前后审议这一切时，他们几乎走到了那一步，但他们先废黜了他……他们迫使他“自愿”退位（我这里得加上引号）。所以这很大程度上说明，他们没有迈出最后那一步。我们在筹备这个展览过程中发现的最有趣的事情之一，就是17世纪人们迈出最后那一步的过程。但在理查二世时期，议会的权力还不足以做到这一点。基本上，他们受到了一定程度的抑制。亨利四世和亨利五世，如果人们到处跑着说：“实际上，你们是篡位者，
Richard the second is the true king. Are they being condemned as traitors? Yeah, so we see at this time, treason, treasonous words start coming into the mix. So this idea of compassing and imagining, it's there's a question of what that actually means, what the action is. Is there an over-action of actually trying to imagine or plot or plan the death of the king? And under Henry IV, we start to see words being brought into that, particularly words around claiming that Richard II is still alive. So we've got an amazing bill in the exhibition of someone called John Whitelock. And he says, I was with the king in Scotland. He is still alive.
理查二世才是真正的国王。”他们会被判为叛国罪吗？是的，所以在那个时期，“叛国言论”开始出现在讨论中。因此，“谋划与图谋”这个概念引发了一个问题：这到底意味着什么？什么是实际行动？是否存在图谋或密谋策划杀害国王的实质性越轨行动？在亨利四世统治时期，我们开始看到言论被引入其中，特别是那些声称理查二世仍然活着的言论。我们在展览中展出了一份非常惊人的议案，关于一个名叫约翰·怀特洛克的人。他说：“我和国王在苏格兰。他还活着。
He should be put back on the throne. He's a conspiracy theorist. Well, he takes it to a great extent. He actually offers to submit himself to the royal justices and put himself in the Tower of London and says, test my story. Oh, that's crunchy. If you find I'm wrong, I will submit to any punishment you ascribe to me. But if I'm right, let me free and put Richard back on the throne.
他应该被重新扶上王位。”他是个阴谋论者。嗯，他把事情闹得很大。他甚至主动提出向皇家法官自首，把自己关进伦敦塔，并说：“去验证我的故事吧。”哦，这可真够劲爆的。如果你们发现我错了，我甘愿接受你们加诸于我的任何惩罚。但如果我是对的，请放了我，并把理查重新扶上王位。
We don't know whether his claim was actually tested because he actually breaks out of the Tower of London and escapes. Oh, does he? And he had an inside man who actually suffers a traitor's fate in his stead. Right. So the guy who helped him sneak out gets hanged drawn and quartered in his place that's harsh so before we go in the second half we'll talk we'll move into the tudors but before we get some break because we've got a few minutes just before the
我们不知道他的说法是否得到了验证，因为他实际上从伦敦塔越狱逃跑了。哦，是吗？而且他有一个内应，代替他承受了叛国者的命运。没错。所以那个帮他悄悄溜走的人代他被处以绞刑、剖腹并分尸。这太严厉了。所以在我们进入下半场、讨论都铎王朝之前，在我们休息一下之前——因为我们还有几分钟时间，就在
break can you tell us something about because you've got some other amazing looking documents here which are from the sort of very late part of the medieval period yeah so what we've got here is that extension of compassing imagining so we have words first of all but then we have ideas about astrology magic necromancy as being treasonous treasonous magic tell me about treasonous magic so this is a story of elena cobham who's often described as a royal a royal witch and she is the wife of humphrey duke of gloucester who is the hit the kings of henryrey, Duke of Gloucester, who is the king, so Henry VI, his uncle. And he's essentially next in line to the throne if Henry VI dies,
休息之前，你能给我们讲讲……因为你们这里还有一些其他看起来非常惊人的文件，它们来自中世纪的极晚期？是的，我们这里展示的是“谋划与图谋”的延伸。首先我们有了言论，然后我们有了关于占星术、魔法、巫术的想法，这些也被视为了叛国。叛国性质的魔法。跟我讲讲叛国性质的魔法？这是一个关于埃莉诺·科巴姆的故事，她常被描述为“皇室女巫”。她是格洛斯特公爵亨利的妻子——抱歉，是格洛斯特公爵汉弗莱的妻子，也就是国王亨利六世的叔叔。如果亨利六世去世，他基本上是王位的第一顺位继承人，
because he hasn't got an heir at this point. And what Elna and her associates are accused of doing is summoning spirits and magical demons to predict when the king will die. So they're not predicting, they're not plotting the death of the king as such. But that's the whole imagining the death, imagining the death of the king. So they're imagining, they're trying to find, work out when this will happen and when Eleanor will become queen.
因为当时国王还没有子嗣。而埃莉诺及其同伙被指控做的事情是召唤精灵和魔法恶魔，来预测国王何时会死。所以他们并不是在预测，他们本身并不是在密谋谋杀国王。但这就是所谓的“图谋杀害”，图谋杀害国王。所以他们在想象、试图找出并计算这一切何时会发生，以及埃莉诺何时能成为王后。
And she's the one who ends up, kind of Game of Thrones style, having to walk the walk of shame through the streets of London. Like Cersei Lannister. Yeah, so we have, her trial's really interesting. So we have two sides to it. There's the trial for treason, which is slightly fudged because they don't have in precedent a way of putting a noble woman on trial at this time. Right, so for women it's different.
而她最终的结局——就像《权力的游戏》里的风格一样——被迫在伦敦街头进行了一场耻辱的游街。就像瑟曦·兰尼斯特那样。是的，所以她的审判非常有趣。我们有两个视角。一个是针对叛国罪的审判，这有点含糊其辞，因为当时他们没有先例来审判一位贵族女性。没错，所以对女性而言情况不同。
Is it the penalty or? So under the Treason Act, well actually the Treason Act doesn't define the punishment of the tradition. But the tradition is that a woman would be burnt rather than hanged, drawn and quartered. But they don't really know. Under Magna Carta, nobles at this time have the right to be tried by a panel of their peers, a jury of their peers. But it doesn't say anything about women so they don't really know how to try try eleanor so they put her on trial as a kind of associate they put her associates properly on trial but they also have this secondary religious tribunal for which we don't have the records and they are the ones that find her guilty of certain heresies and she's made
是刑罚不同吗？根据《叛国法》——实际上《叛国法》并未明确规定叛国的刑罚。但传统上，女性会被烧死，而不是被处以绞刑、剖腹和分尸。但他们其实并不确定。根据《大宪章》，当时的贵族有权由同阶层的陪审团审判。但它对女性没有任何规定，所以他们并不真正知道该如何审判埃莉诺。于是他们把她当作某种从犯来审判，对她的同伙进行了正规的审判。但他们同时还有一个次要的宗教法庭，我们没有相关的审判记录，正是这个宗教法庭裁定她犯有某些异端罪，并迫使她
to walk a public walk of shame. Shame. On three occasions. You'd be very good at that, Tom. You've missed your calling. So the documents that we have about that, what's this specific document? So in the exhibition,
进行公开的耻辱游行。耻辱。总共三次。汤姆，你在这方面肯定很在行。你真是入错了行。那么我们拥有的关于这方面的文件，具体是哪一份文件？所以在展览中，
we've got the indictments against her associates, who are, two of them are, well, one of them is hanged, drawn, and quartered. One of them dies in prison while waiting the results. But we've also got a story of the kind of, what happens after the trial, of them is hanged, drawn and quartered. One of them dies in prison while waiting the results. But we've also got a story of the kind of what happens after the trial, because Eleanor is a very polarizing figure. People love her or people really do not like her. And we have a case here recorded of someone who essentially is very pro Eleanor and anti what has happened in the trial. And she accosts Henry VI while he's riding
我们有针对她同伙的起诉书，其中两人——其中一人被判处绞刑、剖腹和分尸。另一人在等待判决结果期间死于狱中。但我们也有关于审判之后发生的事情的故事……其中一人被判处绞刑、剖腹和分尸。另一人在等待结果期间死于狱中。但我们也有关于审判后发生的事情的故事，因为埃莉诺是一个两极分化非常严重的人物。人们要么极其喜爱她，要么非常厌恶她。我们这里记录了一个案例，某人本质上非常支持埃莉诺，并极力反对审判中的判决结果。此人在亨利六世骑马穿越布莱克希斯时
across Blackheath and essentially says, you are stupid. The whole of England knows that you are stupid. Send Elna back to her husband because as well as this public walk of shame, she's been made to divorce her husband or her marriage has been annulled because it was claimed that she used magic
拦住了他，基本上说道：“你太愚蠢了。全英格兰都知道你是个蠢货。把埃莉诺送回她丈夫身边去吧。”因为除了公开游街示众之外，她还被迫与丈夫离婚，或者说她的婚姻被宣布无效，因为有人声称她当初使用了魔法
to seduce Humphrey in the first place. Actually, that's probably not true. We think it's probably a fertility medicine or fertility magic that's been used. There's a woman called the Witch Next Eye, Marjorie Jourdain. The Witch Next Eye? Next Eye. So Eye is a place near Westminster. Oh, okay.
才诱惑了汉弗莱。事实上，这可能并非事实。我们认为她当时用的可能是一种生育药物或生育魔法。有一个女人被称为“内克斯特眼的魔女”，名叫玛乔丽·茹丹。内克斯特眼的魔女？内克斯特眼（Next Eye）。“Eye”是威斯敏斯特附近的一个地方。哦，原来如此。
So it's the witch that lives near Westminster. Yeah. And she is actually burnt as part of this process because she's accused of providing eleanor with these magical potions these magical remedies okay i mean this is very much the the kind of the traditional understanding of how medieval this is exactly yeah as a modern historian this is precisely how i imagine medieval history to be which is fertility rituals people shouting that other people are stupid i mean but but having said
所以这就是住在威斯敏斯特附近的女巫。是的。她实际上在这个过程中被烧死了，因为她被指控向埃莉诺提供这些神奇的药水和神奇的疗法。好吧，这简直就是人们对中世纪的传统刻板印象……确实如此，是的。作为一名现代历史学家，这正是我想象中的中世纪历史的模样：求子仪式、人们高喊别人是蠢话。不过，话虽如此
that i mean eleanor isn't burned did she i mean she she gets kind of packed off yeah she's she's sent away for life imprisonment in the end but um yeah no no physical punishment but in reaction to this they change the law so they now work out this this naughty question they hadn't got before and peer wrestlers of the realm are now put on trial by a jury of their male peers right and so that will become important for the tudors and um the last document that we should look at before we go to the break is um that's the best aesthetically it's it's a wonderful document issued by the first of the tudors henry the seventh so this is a huge role. It's a massive role. It's a massive role. I mean if you unfurled that role, Tom,
埃莉诺并没有被烧死，对吧？她最后被流放了……是的，她最终被判终身监禁，但是……是的，没有遭受肉体惩罚。但作为对此事的反应，他们修改了法律，现在他们解决了之前没能搞清楚的这个棘手问题：此后，王国的同阶贵族必须由其男性同阶陪审团进行审判。没错，这对于都灵……哦不，都铎王朝将变得非常重要。在我们休息之前我们要看的最后一份文件是……这是美学上最棒的，是一份由都铎王朝的第一位君主亨利七世发出的绝妙文件。这是一个巨大的卷轴。这是一个庞大的卷轴。这是一个巨大的卷轴。汤姆，如果你把那个卷轴展开，
I'm not exaggerating to say you could unfurl that role and it would stretch from here to the exit of the National Archives. You could carpet the whole corridor, couldn't you? You could carpet Tom Holland's house with that role. So that's in the name of Henry VII. Who is the traitor who is being figured in that role?
我毫不夸张地说，你可以把那个卷轴展开，它能从这里一直延伸到国家档案馆的出口。你可以用它铺满整个走廊，不是吗？你可以用那个卷轴铺满汤姆·霍兰德的房子。所以这是以亨利七世的名义发布的。那个卷轴里描绘的叛国者是谁？
So this is a very interesting document and entry. This is the attainder of Richard III. So again, that same tainting process. Except when this is brought before Parliament, Richard's already dead because Henry has killed and defeated him at the Battle of Bosworth. Henry Tudor, categorically a traitor at Bosworth he he stands up against the king in open battle with banners unfurled and the king dies in that battle except because henry is now on the throne he posthumously attains richard iii and he does this presumably he's not calling him richard iii he's calling him duke of gloucester or whatever yes richard duke of gloucester and what he does is he backdates the start of his reign to the day before the Battle of Bosworth. And by doing so, he says, Richard was a traitor. I was a king. You traitorously stood against me in battle.
所以这是一个非常有趣的文件和条目。这是对理查三世的剥夺公权令。所以说，同样是那种污名化的过程。不过当这个被提交到议会时，理查已经死了，因为亨利在博斯沃思战役中杀死了他并击败了他。亨利·都铎，在博斯沃思战役中显然是个叛徒，他带着展开的旗帜在公开战斗中挺身对抗国王，国王在那场战斗中死了。不过因为亨利现在登上了王位，他追封理查三世为叛国，他这么做时，据我推测——他不是叫他理查三世，而是叫他格洛斯特公爵什么的——是的，格洛斯特公爵理查，他所做的是将他统治的开始时间倒推到博斯沃思战役的前一天。通过这样做，他说，理查是个叛徒。我是国王。你在战斗中叛国反对我。
Right. And so I'm obviously an absolute whiz at reading medieval handwriting. And I can't help noticing. So this one is in English, right? Yes. So by the later half of the 15th century, these records start to appear in English rather than the Anglo-Norman or the Latin in previous years. And so it was introduced in Parliament. Presumably Parliament is either packed with Henry's supporters or, you know, people have just tailored their cloth to fit the new regimes. So with these kinds of things, nobody would vote against them, right? So it's interesting. With Richard III's attainder, we actually know that there was a bit of dissent, particularly among the commons, about how this was being received.
对。所以我显然是个阅读中世纪手稿的绝对高手。我禁不住注意到。所以这份是用英文写的，对吧？是的。所以在15世纪的后半叶，这些记录开始以英文出现，而不是前几年的盎格鲁-诺曼语或拉丁语。所以它是被提交到议会的。据推测，议会要么塞满了亨利的支持者，要么就是，你知道的，人们只是见风使舵来适应新政权。所以对于这类事情，没有人会投票反对它们，对吧？所以这很有趣。对于理查三世的剥夺公权令，我们实际上知道当时确实存在一些异议，特别是平民之间，关于这是如何被接受的。
And we don't have records of that in the parliamentary rolls, but we have it from other accounts that this was sore questioned with, this but ultimately henry's in a position of power at this point and to stand against him and to go against that wouldn't really have been okay so the battle of bosworth obviously ends the middle ages modernity begins the tudors arrive and i think that um in the break we'll have a break now and then when we come back we'll look at how the Tudors used... Top treason coming out of it. Top treason coming. But if you want to see the documents that we've been discussing, or any others, do come to this incredible exhibition, Treason, People, Power and Plot, at the National Archives.
我们在议会卷宗中没有这些记录，但我们从其他记载中了解到，这件事受到了尖锐的质问，但最终亨利在这个时候处于权力地位，起来反对他并违抗这一点其实是不行的。所以博斯沃思战役显然结束了中世纪，现代性开始了，都铎王朝登场了。我想，我们现在休息一会儿，等我们回来后，我们将看看都铎王朝是如何利用……随之而来的最高叛国罪。最高叛国罪要来了。但如果你想看我们一直在讨论的文件，或者任何其他文件，一定要来国家档案馆观看这场不可思议的展览：叛国：人民、权力与阴谋。
It is absolutely free. You don't even need to book it. And you can get information on the opening hours and all that kind of stuff at the National Archives website, nationalarchives.gov.uk. We will be back with Tudor treason trials. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&AA we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are still here in the great cavernous expanse of the National Archives,
它是完全免费的。你甚至不需要预订。你可以在国家档案馆的网站 nationalarchives.gov.uk 上获取开放时间和所有这类事情的信息。我们将带着都铎王朝的叛国审判回归。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《其余皆是娱乐》。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、少量八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及优先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那就是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《其余皆是历史》。我们仍然身处国家档案馆那巨大如洞穴般的广阔空间里，
surrounded by parchments and rolls and all kinds of weird and wonderful things from their treason exhibition. And Tom, we have reached the top century for treason, which is that... I know, all treason fans love the Tudors, don't they? Yeah, well, we should discuss. We will get on to discussing who our favourite and least and least favorite tudor traitors are spoiler alert obviously thomas moore is a very bad man um so ewan uh in the first half you were taking us through a lot of medieval treason so what should we start with so i have here i'm rustling this piece of paper which i can i'll reassure people it's not a piece of parchment it's not a piece of parchment it is a it is a printout of a transcript so whereas anne late queen of england lately our
周围环绕着羊皮纸、卷轴以及来自他们的叛国展的各种奇异而美妙的东西。汤姆，我们已经迎来了叛国罪的黄金世纪，那就是……我知道，所有的叛国粉都喜欢都铎王朝，对吧？是的，好吧，我们应该讨论一下。我们将继续讨论谁是我们最喜欢和最讨厌的都铎叛徒——剧透预警，显然托马斯·莫尔是个非常坏的人。嗯，尤恩，在前半部分，你带我们了解了很多中世纪的叛国罪，那么我们应该从什么开始呢？所以我这里有，我在沙沙作响地翻弄这张纸，我可以向大家保证，这不是一张羊皮纸，这不是一张羊皮纸，它是一份文字记录的打印件。因此，鉴于安妮，英格兰已故王后，最近我们的……
wife lately attainted so everyone knows where we're going with this this is anne boleyn so anne boleyn's treason trial she is tried by peers isn't she she is yes so she's guilty of what witchcraft imagining the death of the king as well so not witchcraft okay the accusations against us we've got her trial records in the exhibition and they they practically never come out so this is an amazing opportunity to come and see them they accused her of incest with her brother and other several um courtiers and of plotting the death of the king and inciting them to plot the death of the king but there's no charges in here of witchcraft even though henry thought that henry put it about didn't he that he'd been bewitched into marriage but they don't they don't think that'll stand up in court
妻子，最近被剥夺了公权——所以每个人都知道我们要去哪里，这是安妮·博林。所以安妮·博林的叛国审判，她是由贵族审判的，对吧？是的，所以她犯了什么罪？巫术，还有密谋谋害国王。所以不是巫术？好的，对我们的指控——我们在展览中有她的审判记录，它们几乎从不展出，所以这是一个来看它们的绝佳机会。他们指控她与她的兄弟和其他几位朝臣乱伦，并密谋谋害国王以及煽动他们密谋谋害国王。但这里面没有关于巫术的指控，尽管亨利认为——亨利曾到处宣扬，对吧？说他被迷魂才结了婚。但他们不认为这能在法庭上站住脚。
basically it's not recorded in the trial proceedings but they do go into um a lot of detail in other instances they talk about her and her brother george and tongues in each other's mouths and all this kind of this detail. But does that count as treason? Because you're, I don't know, committing, you're cuckolding the king. Does that come under the remit of the Treason Act? So for the men involved, it potentially does. But for Anne, that's not necessarily a charge that would stand up.
基本上，这没有记录在审判程序中，但他们在其他情况下确实深入探讨了很多细节，他们谈论她和她的兄弟乔治舌吻以及所有这些细节。但这算叛国罪吗？因为你在，我不知道，你在做，你给国王戴了绿帽子。这属于叛国罪法案的管辖范围吗？所以对于涉案的男士来说，潜在地是的。但对于安妮来说，这不一定是能站得住脚的指控。
So which is why they have to accuse her of plotting the death of the king and inciting. And so that's what gets her. She's convicted of treason. Yes. Okay, so the next question is, the penalty for a woman is to be burnt. So why is she not burnt? So it's described as an act of leniency on the king's behalf. I'm not sure that's quite the way that we should be thinking about this. But he arranges, and we should be thinking about this um but he arranges
所以这就是为什么他们必须指控她密谋谋害国王和煽动。这就是定她罪的原因。她被判叛国罪名成立。是的。好的，那么下一个问题是，对女性的惩罚是火刑。那她为什么没有被火刑？所以这被描述为国王表现出的宽大处理。我不确定这是否是我们应该看待这件事的方式。但他安排了——我们应该这样看待这件事，但他安排了——
and we have to warrant for this he arranges for her to be beheaded at the tower instead of being burnt here and this is his he's writing to william kingston the constable of the tower and he says um we moved by pity do not wish the same and to be committed to be burned by fire but we command that immediately after receipt of these presents upon the green within our tower of London, the foresaid the head of the same and shall be caused to be cut off. Interestingly, this document is now in a book. It's bound in a book.
我们有这道手令——他安排在塔内将她斩首，而不是被烧死。这里，这是他在写信给伦敦塔总管威廉·金斯顿，他说：“鉴于我们出于怜悯，不希望上述人员被火刑烧死，我们命令，在收到本文件后，立即在伦敦塔内的草坪上，将上述人员的头部砍掉。”有趣的是，这份文件现在在一本书里。它被装订在一本书里。
So that's, it's not, it's not on a, they've dispensed with roles. I mean, I'm betraying my ignorance of medieval archives here. So we have the trial records are on parchment rolls. Yeah.
所以，它不是，它不是在——他们已经不用卷轴了。我的意思是，我在这里暴露了我对中世纪档案馆的无知。所以我们有审判记录是在羊皮纸卷轴上。是的。
Um, but they're actually, there's an, there's an interesting materiality to them in that they're part of what are called the bags of secrets, or the bag of secrets. And this is a whole series of records
嗯，但它们实际上，它们有一种有趣的物质性，因为它们是被称为“秘密之袋”（bags of secrets，或秘密之袋）的一部分。这是一系列完整的记录，
that are literally kept in parchment bags, and they're kept in a secret cupboard at Westminster to which only three people have the key. Even now, isn't it? So not today, not since the 19th century. And these are trials that are particularly constitutionally important or have some sort of particular importance and they'd literally take the records and put them away where they could be kept secretly so as i understand it
它们字面意义上被放在羊皮袋里，保存在威斯敏斯特的一个秘密橱柜里，只有三个人有钥匙。即使是现在也是吗？所以今天不是，自19世纪以来就不是了。这些是宪法上特别重要或者具有某种特殊重要性的审判，他们字面意义上把记录拿走并收好，把它们保密存放。所以据我理解，
part of the you know henry the eighth brings in new refinements of the treason act and one of the refinements in the specific case of amber lynn is that it becomes treasonous to defend amberlin is that still on the statute book could tudor historians be accused of treason so pretty much all of henry the apes um additions to treason legislation are removed as soon as he's dead by his son and his son's counsel right they say he's gone too far and they take it right back to 1352 and they do that actually throughout so obviously henry breaks with the roman church and that creates a whole lot of new treasons in and of itself but as the country moves from being catholic to being protestant going back to catholic again you see new legislation being introduced and then immediately repealed by his successor so
亨利八世引入了对叛国罪法案的新修正，其中针对安妮·博林特定案件的一个修正案是：为安妮·博林辩护也变成了叛国罪。这还在法典里吗？都铎历史学家会被指控犯有叛国罪吗？所以几乎亨利八世对叛国立法的 所有补充内容，在他死后立刻就被他的儿子和儿子的委员会废除了。对吧？他们说他走得太远了，他们直接把它倒退回了1352年。他们实际上在各个方面都这么做了——所以显然亨利与罗马教会决裂，这本身就引发了大量的新叛国罪。但随着国家从天主教变为新教，再次变回天主教，你会看到新立法被引入，然后立刻被他的继任者废除。所以
they always go back to 1352 it seems to be that they they're seeing it as the core legislation it's the treason equivalent of magna carta yes exactly the same so so um you talk about um how the introduction the reformation complicates the whole business of treason because obviously uh if if you don't want to sign up to the Reformation as a matter of principle, then you have to decide whether you know what is the worst to to forfeit your immortal soul or to risk your life by committing treason. decides that he would rather lose his head than his soul is Thomas More. The idea that people will betray their country rather than their ideals, do you think that concept begins with More in British history? It's a challenge that's never really there in the same way before Thomas More. But I think you do see, and thinking back to Richard II's reign for example you do see nobles standing up against they're not afraid to suffer the consequences
他们似乎总是回到1352年，这似乎被他们视为核心立法。这就是大宪章的叛国罪版本。是的，完全一样。所以，你谈到了宗教改革是如何使叛国罪的整个事情变得复杂的，因为显然，如果你作为原则问题不想签署宗教改革，那么你就必须决定，你知道的，什么是更坏的——是丧失你永恒的灵魂，还是通过犯下叛国罪来冒生命危险。决定他宁愿失去脑袋也不愿失去灵魂的是托马斯·莫尔。人们宁愿背叛国家也不愿背叛自己的理想这种想法，你认为这个概念在英国历史上始于莫尔吗？这是一个在托马斯·莫尔之前从未以同样方式真正存在的挑战。但我认为你确实看到——回想理查二世的统治时期，例如——你确实看到贵族挺身而出，他们不怕承受后果，
and we do get people particularly in Richard II's reign saying I will stand up for these beliefs So those are kind of Lollards and people like that is it? So you get it on a Lollard basis but you also get it amongst the nobility so with the Lords Appellant and then the Counter Appellants. So we argue the
我们确实看到有人，特别是在理查二世统治时期说：我将为这些信仰挺身而出。所以这些有点像罗洛派（Lollards）这样的人，对吧？所以你在罗洛派的基础上能看到这一点，但你也能在贵族中看到这一点——比如上诉贵族（Lords Appellant）以及后来的反上诉贵族。所以我们争辩说，
national interest is not being served by this particular king basically but that's slightly different isn't it i mean that's that's a kind of opinion the government's no you know good but saying you know my principles are more important than my loyalty to a king i mean that's a kind of slight refinement of it because that's where we'll go with say you know the french revolutionary the french revolution the communists and all that kind of stuff. And indeed, ISIS, that these are people who passionately believe that their loyalty to ideals should trump their loyalty to the monarch or to the state. Yeah, I think that's correct. In the earlier period, it's very much the process is not right.
这个特定的国王基本上没有为国家利益服务，但这有点不同，对吧？我的意思是，那是一种意见，认为政府不好，但说“我的原则比我对国王的忠诚更重要”——我的意思是，那是对它的一种轻微细化，因为这就是我们要走向的方向，比如法国大革命、法国大革命、共产主义者以及所有这类事情。事实上，还有伊斯里斯（ISIS），这些人坚信他们对理想的忠诚应该凌驾于他们对君主或国家的忠诚之上。是的，我认为这很准确。在早期阶段，更多的是这个程序不对，
I'm not getting a fair trial. And that's what they're standing up for. But you're right that with the break from the Roman Church, we do see this spiritual element being brought into it. And it's there with the Lollards, but it's never really there on a nationwide scale as it is with the break from Rome.
我没有得到公平的审判。这就是他们挺身而出维护的。但你说得对，随着与罗马教会的决裂，我们确实看到了这种精神元素被引入其中。它在罗洛派中存在，但它从来没有像与罗马决裂那样在全国范围内真正存在过。
So before we move on to the next document, let's just focus for a second on Thomas More. I think you're unsound on Thomas More, Tom, because we've established in previous episodes of The Rest is History that you're, I think, deep down... Crypto-Catholic. I think you're unsound on Thomas Moore, Tom. Because we've established in previous episodes of The Rest is History that you're, I think, deep down... Crypto-Catholic.
所以在我们转向下一份文件之前，让我们花一秒钟专注于托马斯·莫尔。我认为你在托马斯·莫尔的问题上立场不稳，汤姆，因为我们在《其余皆是历史》以前的几期中已经确立了，我认为你内心深处……是个隐蔽的天主教徒。我认为你在托马斯·莫尔的问题上立场不稳，汤姆。因为我们在《其余皆是历史》以前的几期中已经确立了，我认为你内心深处……是个隐蔽的天主教徒。
I think you're a bit unsound on The Reformation, aren't you? It depends on your definition of soundness. I think I'm impeccably sound on it. So on Thomas Moore, are you a Hillary Mantellite, or... No, I'm not.
我觉得你在宗教改革的问题上有点立场不稳，对吧？这取决于你对“立场稳固”的定义。我认为我在这个问题上无可挑剔。所以在托马斯·莫尔的问题上，你是希拉里·曼特尔（Hillary Mantel）的粉丝，还是……不，我不是。
Yeah, I see. No, I'm a man for all seasons. Are you? You're a man for all seasons. Yeah. I really am. I'm more... I'm absolutely team Thomas Cromwell. I love Thomas Cromwell. Yeah,omwell i love thomas but so cromwell also ends up with his head off and that is that is unjust
对，我明白。不，我是个四季之人（A Man for All Seasons）。你是吗？你是个四季之人。对。我真的是。我更……我绝对是托马斯·克伦威尔（Thomas Cromwell）战队的。我爱托马斯·克伦威尔。是的，克伦威尔，我爱托马斯……但克伦威尔最后也掉了脑袋，那是不公正的，
isn't it so he's not brought to trial henry just says i'm bringing a bill of attainder off with his head but he's not guilty of treason is he is he guilty of treason he is well because because a bill of attainder is somebody's nodding actually we haven't told the audience but there are people in the background and people are nodding yeah because the bill of it you know if you're if you're if you're tainted then then you you're you're a traitor and so and so that remains um a kind of arrow in the quiver of the monarch so yeah from from the wars of the roses onward basically parliamentary attainder is the way you go to prosecute someone for treason so it's the it's the go-to measure because if you have parliament support you introduce it and they are attainted in fact by parliament so it's the definitely becomes the go-to measure but again thomas moore's records
对吧？所以他没有被送上法庭审判，亨利只是说：我要提出一项剥夺公权法案，砍掉他的头。但他没有犯叛国罪，对吧？他犯叛国罪了吗？他……好吧，因为因为剥夺公权法案是——有人在点头，实际上我们没有告诉观众，但后台有人在点头。是的，因为剥夺公权法案，你知道的，如果你被剥夺了公权，那么你就是一个叛徒，所以这仍然是君主箭袋里的一支箭——所以，是的，从玫瑰战争开始，基本上议会剥夺公权就是起诉某人叛国的方法。所以这是首选措施，因为如果你有议会支持，你引入它，他们实际上就被议会剥夺了公权。所以它绝对成为了首选措施。但再次说明，托马斯·莫尔的记录
are squirreled away into these bags of secrets and we actually have that they're really interesting in that they record his own words in them and they record them in English as opposed to Latin so that they can bring him down on these words about, for example, the sword of two edges. If you one, you can either forfeit your soul or forfeit your life. Yeah. And they record these words in the official records. We should say at this point also that if you are accused of treason, you don't get a defence lawyer, do you? Not until the 1690s. Not at this period, no.
被塞进了这些秘密之袋里。我们实际上发现它们非常有趣，因为它们记录了他自己的原话，并且它们是用英文而不是拉丁文记录的，这样他们就可以用这些话来打倒他。例如，关于“双刃之剑”。如果你选其一，你要么丧失灵魂，要么丧失生命。是的。他们在官方记录中记录了这些话。此时我们也应该说，如果你被指控叛国，你没有辩护律师，对吧？直到1690年代才有。在这个时期没有，是的。
You do see at the start of Henry's reign moves to start making a fairer process in that further proof is required. But at this point, you still don't get that defence that you would get in later years. So we've got two more documents to go. Let's look at this. I mean, this is a huge, again,
你确实在亨利统治之初看到有举措开始建立一个更公正的程序，即需要进一步的证据。但在此时，你仍然没有你在后期会得到的辩护。所以我们还有两份文件要看。让我们看看这个。我的意思是，这是一个巨大的，再次，
so this is not really it's not bound in a book is it it's um i don't know what you'd call this is a technical term for this kind of arrangement so it's a modern this is a modern binding of very miscellaneous documents put together this is all about porridge isn't it this this document this is just a random file fans of porridge yeah this is this is the moment you've been waiting for porridge and treason porridge and trees we we do very niche subjects and the rest is history so talk us through porridge and treason so this is the act um brought in for poisoning in henry the eighth reign and this is all about a man called richard roose richard roose is a cook and he works in the household of the
所以这真的不是——它没有装订在一本书里，对吧？它是一份——我不知道你该怎么称呼这种排列的专业术语。所以这是一份现代的——这是一份将非常杂乱的文件放在一起的现代装订。这全是关于粥的对吧？这份文件，这只是一份随机的档案。粥的粉丝们，对，这就是你一直在等待的时刻：粥与叛国。粥与叛国！我们在《其余皆是历史》中总是做非常小众的主题。所以给我们讲讲粥与叛国。所以这是亨利八世统治时期为毒杀行为而引入的法案，这全都是关于一个叫理查·鲁斯（Richard Roose）的人。理查·鲁斯是一名厨师，他在
bishop of rochester um john fisher and one day the porridge gets poisoned in the morning. Now, the bishop doesn't actually eat his porridge that morning. And so he's absolutely fine. He's deemed to be, they record that he's sick. And so he doesn't have porridge that day. But other members in the household do eat this porridge. And there's also a lot of this porridge is given out to local poor people as alms. And it's recorded that Roos had put something in the porridge while it was brewing and he's poisoning people. Now, we don't know how all of this, we don't know what actually happened because the Bishop of Rochester is a big supporter of Catherine of Aragon. So very much anti-Amblin and the King and Amblin's family
罗切斯特主教约翰·费舍尔（John Fisher）的府中工作。有一天早上，粥被下毒了。现在，主教那天早上实际上并没有吃他的粥。所以他完全没事。他被认为——他们记录说他生病了。所以他那天没有喝粥。但府中的其他成员确实喝了这粥。而且这粥的很大一部分作为施舍分发给了当地的穷人。据记载，鲁斯在熬粥时往里面放了某种东西，他在毒害人们。现在，我们不知道这一切是如何——我们不知道究竟发生了什么，因为罗切斯特主教是阿拉贡的凯瑟琳的坚定支持者。所以非常反安妮·博林，而国王和安妮·博林的家人对他的这种做法以及对凯瑟琳的支持并不是特别高兴。所以有一些说法认为，这可能是一种试图干掉约翰·费舍尔的方式，但我们无法确定。理查·鲁斯在某份编年史记录中实际上被记载为把毒药放进去作为
are not particularly happy with him doing so and supporting Catherine. So there are some suggestions that this may have been a way to try and bump off John Fisher, but we don't know for sure. Richard Roos has actually recorded in one Chronicle account as having put the poison in as
一个玩笑。他认为人们会有点生病，但不会死。粥的玩笑。但我们看到的是，他被带了过来，最初被指控谋杀，因为这基本上就是他所做的事。但亨利八世对总体的下毒行为非常偏执。
a joke. He thinks people will get a bit sick, but not that they'll die. Porridge banter. But what we see is he's brought in and he's originally charged with murder because that is what he's essentially done. But Henry VIII is very paranoid against poisoning generally.
这是他们在罗马干的事。这是他们在教皇廷干的事。这不是在英格兰发生的事。坦率地说，他似乎对此感到惊恐万状。我们看到的是，在这里的桌子上，我们有关于下毒的法案草案。在展览中，我们实际上有议会卷宗中的最终正式版本。我们看到的是语言上的改变，使得下毒从谋杀变成了严重叛国罪。这发生在事后。
It's a thing they do at Rome. It's a thing they do at the papal court. It's not a thing that happens in England. And he's frankly terrified by it seemingly. And what we see is, so on the table here, we've got the draft act for poisoning. In the exhibition, we've actually got the final enrolled version in the parliament rolls. And what we see is a change in the language that makes poisoning move from being murder to being high treason. And that is happening after the fact.
所以理查·鲁斯，它在他被——毒害谁的时候改变了？毒害任何人。任何人。这是——我的意思是，你有点暗示说这是他们在意大利或什么的搞的阴险的外国勾当。罗马式的行为。罗马式的行为。
So Richard Roos, it changes while he's been... Poisoning who? Poisoning anybody. Anybody. And is this... I mean, you kind of implied that this is a sinister foreign thing that they get up to in Italy or whatever. Romish behaviour. Romish behaviour.
那是它的潜台词吗？正派的新教徒不会到处在粥里下毒，或者……所以此时，我们还没进入新教时代。我们仍然处于——他在此时还没有与罗马决裂，这是1531年。但有一种观点认为这是一件很外国的做法，而且它也借鉴了被称为“轻叛国罪”（petry treason）的概念。那是另一种形式的叛国罪，它也包含在1352年的法案中，该法案谈到——它规定以与国王相同的条款，试图包围和想象你的主人的死，或者杀死你的主人，这即是叛国。那是叛国行为。所以，鲁斯的案子，我认为也借鉴了一点这一点。对。然后，所以这现在已经不在法典里了，对吧？我的意思是，去毒害某人，你并不犯叛国罪。所以，那在亨利八世统治结束时被废除了。
Is that the kind of the subtext for it? That decent Protestants don't go around poisoning porridge or... So at this point, we're not into the Protestant era yet. We're still in the... He around poisoning porridge or so at this point we're not into the protestant era yet we're still in the he's not broken from rome at this point this is 1531 but there is the idea that it's a foreign thing to do but also it draws on concepts of what's called petty treason now that's a different form of treason that is also in the 1352 act and that talks that makes it treason to try, in the same terms as the king,
如果我们还没进入新教时代，我们仍然处于——他在此时还没有与罗马决裂，这是1531年，但有一种观点认为这是一件很外国的做法，而且它也借鉴了被称为“轻叛国罪”的概念。那是另一种形式的叛国罪，它也包含在1352年的法案中，该法案规定以与国王相同的条款，试图包围和想象你的主人的死，或者杀死你的主人，这即是叛国。那是叛国行为。所以，鲁斯的案子，我认为也借鉴了一点这一点。
to try and compass and imagine the death of your master or to kill your master. That is treasonous behavior. So, Roos' case, I think, draws a bit on that as well. Right. And then, so that's off the statute book now, right? I mean, to poison somebody, you're not guilty of treason. So, that is repealed at the end of Henry VIII's reign.
对。然后，所以这现在已经不在法典里了，对吧？我的意思是，去毒害某人，你并不犯叛国罪。所以，那在亨利八世统治结束时被废除了。
If I poison Tom, that's not treachery. I'm your master. I feel hanging, drawing, and quartering would be too good for you. Too good, right, I see. Let's move on to the final document. I'm not even going to dignify that ludicrous remark with the reply. Well, it is worth considering briefly in that, actually, Richard Roos' punishment is not to be hanged,'t he gets boiled you'd boil me he is publicly boiled
如果我毒死汤姆，那不是背叛。我是你的主人。我觉得凌迟处死对你来说都太便宜了。太便宜了，对吧，我明白。让我们转向最后一份文件。我甚至不会用回答来抬高那个荒谬的言论。好吧，简短地考虑一下还是值得的，事实上，理查·鲁斯的惩罚不是被绞死，而是被煮死——你会把我煮了——他在史密斯菲尔德（Smithfield）被公开煮死。
to death in smithfield smithfield so and that's a horrible death um being but being unlike being drawn and quarters right okay but just just to go back thomas moore uh thomas cromwell and berlin uh catherine howard all have their heads chopped off. So that idea that you are upper class, generally you're not going to have horrible things. The kind of the public, the humiliating agonizing deaths, these are for the people from the
史密斯菲尔德。所以那是一种可怕的死法——被煮，但与被车裂不同。对，好吧。但只是——回到托马斯·莫尔、托马斯·克伦威尔、安妮·博林、凯瑟琳·霍华德，他们的脑袋都被砍掉了。所以那种认为你是上流社会，通常就不会遭遇可怕事情的想法。那种公开的、羞辱性的、痛苦的死法，是留给下层阶级的人的。罗伯特·阿斯克（Robert Asquith）被关在一个——他被关在约克或什么地方的铁笼里绞死了，对吧？你知道那个来自“恩典朝圣”叛乱的人。他们确实喜欢对那些挺身而出的人施以特别恐怖的死法——
lower orders. Robert Asquith was hung in a he was hanged in a cage wasn't he, in York or something. You know the guy from the rebellion Pilgrim of Grace. They do like to come up with particularly horrific deaths of people wasn't he in york or something you know the the guy from the rebellion pilgrimage of grace they do like to come up with particularly horrific deaths of people who have who have stood up um so john old old castles rebellion in the in the 15th century he is essentially hanged and burnt at the same time it's combining heresy and treason in richard ruse's case it's meant to visualize the
你知道那个来自“恩典朝圣”叛乱的人。他们确实喜欢对那些挺身而出的人施以特别恐怖的死法——比如约翰·老城堡爵士（John Oldcastle）在15世纪的叛乱中，他基本上被同时绞死和烧死。这是将异端和叛国结合在一起。在理查·鲁斯的案子里，这是为了具象化下毒煮粥的行为，所以他被放进和拿出沸水——我被放进去了好几次——但那种想法，回到15世纪初的那种想法：你可以被定罪，你可以同时成为叛徒和异端——我的意思是，在伊丽莎白统治时期以及后来的詹姆斯一世统治时期，那是国王和女王们不太愿意参与的事情，对吧？因为在伊丽莎白统治时期，那些渡海而来的耶稣会士主要被谴责为叛徒，而不是异端。当我们来到最后一份文件时——这可能是英国历史上最著名的叛国展示，火药阴谋——你那美妙的展览在11月5日开幕的这个展览。同样，他们被谴责为叛徒，而不是异端。王室和国家非常反对人们支持天主教的阴谋，例如。但也有这样一种感觉：你可以是一个 recusant（拒绝出席英国国教礼拜的人）并且你可以私下礼拜，但你不能支持外国势力对抗君主。随着与罗马的决裂，这在很大程度上变得更加契合正在发生的事情。伊丽莎白统治的大部分时间里，宗教叛国罪在很大程度上占据了首要地位。所以你手头的那份文件，这是来自火药阴谋的。你想给我们讲讲这是什么吗？是的，这是蒙特鹰勋爵信（Mount Eagle letter）。
act of poisoning porridge so he's taken in and out of the boiling water i was taken in on several occasions but but that idea so that idea back in the the early 15th century that you can be condemned you can be simultaneously a traitor and a heretic i mean under elizabeth and then under james the first that's something that the kings are let and queens are less keen to engage in, isn't it? Because under Elizabeth, the Jesuits who were coming over are condemned very much as traitors, not as heretics. And when we come to the last document, which is probably the most famous display of treason in British history, the gunpowder plot, this exhibition that your
哦，是的，我们喜欢蒙特鹰勋爵信，对吧？我们确实喜欢，因为我们做过一期关于火药阴谋的节目。所以给我们讲讲蒙特鹰勋爵信，对于那些傻到没有听过节目的听众来说。好吧，他们现在可以听了，对它产生兴趣，然后冲去听——他们现在可以从尤恩那里听到独家预览了。他们可以来展览中看它，因为它将
wonderful exhibition opens on the 5th of November. Again, they are condemned as traitors, not as heretics. The crown and state are very much against people supporting Catholic plots, for example. But there is also a sense that you can be a recusant and you can privately worship, but you can't support foreign powers against the monarch. And that is something that, with the break from Rome, becomes considerably more part of what's going on. Most of Elizabeth's reign is very much religious treasons coming to the fore. So the document that you've got, so this is from the Gunpowder Plot. Do you want to talk us through what this is? Yes, this is the Mount Eagle letter.
公开展出。所以这是一封信，它基本上被送达——在火药阴谋即将发生的前几天被送到蒙特鹰勋爵手中。它基本上警告他不要去议会，去他的乡村庄园。它基本上说，这不是一个玩笑。
Oh yeah, we love the Mount Eagle letter, don't we? We do, because we did an episode on Gunpowder Plot. So tell us about the Mount Eagle letter, for those people who've been foolish enough not to listen to air. Well they can listen to it now, have an interest in it and then rush off and listen to the They'll have a sneak preview now from Ewan. And they can come and see it in the exhibition because it's going to be
不要去议会，因为会有糟糕的事情发生。这不是演习。他们会遭受如此沉重的打击。是那封吗？议会将遭受可怕的打击。是的。是的。作为这件事的结果，他们去调查并最终发现了火药。
out on display as well. So this is a letter that is essentially brought, it's delivered to Mount Eagle a few days before the gunpowder plot is about to take place. And it essentially warns him to not go to Parliament, to go to his country estate. And it says, essentially, this is not a joke.
他们第一次没有找到。他们以为盖伊·福克斯是个仆人。但再次返回时，他们找到了火药。有趣的是，火药阴谋，就思考这种从国王到国家的转变而言：一方面，他们的目标是国王，但也是议会中的国王，以及如果它继续进行本会造成的机构破坏，但它的目标也是新教信仰，这就是为什么它成为英国新教的象征，对吧？你知道的——一直延续到20世纪——我猜现在那已经褪色了，但这就是为什么它是绝对的巅峰——火药叛国与阴谋。是的，确实。人们可能不知道关于火药阴谋的一件有趣的事情是，实际上随后颁布了立法，将11月5日定为公共庆祝日、公共感恩节，这实际上直接变成了立法。我们有这方面的细节。它使之成为一个全国感恩节。所以我想我们已经接近尾声了，对吧，汤姆？
Don't go to Parliament because bad things will happen. This is not a drill. They will receive such a blow. Is that the one? The Parliament will receive a terrible blow. Yeah. Yeah. And as a consequence of this, they go investigating and they find eventually the gunpowder.
好吧，这是一个完美的结局，因为正如我们所说，你们的展览将在11月5日开幕。叛国：人民、权力与阴谋。所以在我们彻底结束之前，尤恩，你可以从这张桌子上拯救一个叛徒，并且你可以坚决谴责一个。他们是谁？
They don't find it the first time. They think that Guy Fawkes is a servant. But on going back again, they find the gunpowder. And it's interesting, the gunpowder plot, in terms of thinking about this move from crown to state. Because on one hand are they're targeting the king but also the king in parliament and that institutional damage that would have happened had it gone ahead but it but it's also targeting the protestant faith and that's why it becomes the emblem of british protestantism isn't it for you know i mean right the way into the 20th century
这是一个非常好的问题。我想我不得不拯救理查·鲁斯。那个下毒的、煮粥的人。因为我认为这是一个可怕的——如果这是一个玩笑，我认为这是一个可怕的，如果这是一个玩笑，这是一个出了可怕差错的玩笑。但归根结底，他是一个卷入远比这宏大得多的政治关切之中的人。好的，那你打算谴责谁？
i guess that's faded now but that's why it is the absolute arc gunpowder treason and plot yeah yeah definitely and one of the interesting things that people might not know about the gunpowder plot is that actually there's legislation put in place afterwards to make um the 5th of november a public celebration a public thanksgiving and that is actually brought into legislation directly. And we have the details of that. And it makes it a national day of Thanksgiving. So I think we've reached the end, haven't we, Tom?
总得有人走。总得有人走。如果你比较讲究，你会选理查三世，对吧？因为他已经死了。理查三世有很多支持者，如果你谴责理查三世，你在推特上会遭到无休止的网暴。我要说——盖伊·福克斯，带点争议地，因为我认为他的目标太广泛了——
Well, it's the perfect end because your exhibition, as we said, is opening on the 5th of November. Treason, people, power and plot. So before we just completely sign off, Ewan, you can save one traitor from this table and you can definitively condemn one. Who are they?
这是对体制如此广泛的攻击，它确实完成了从国王到国家的转变。你本可以跳出这张桌子选择托马斯·莫尔，你没有，没关系。不，我不认为——我认为盖伊·福克斯是完美的选择，因为11月5日，是的，它是火药叛国与阴谋的象征，而那正是国家档案馆这场精彩展览开幕的日子。汤姆，让我重申一下。什么？
That is a very good question. I think I would have to save Richard Roos. The poison, the porridge man. Because I think it's a horrible, if it is a joke think it's a horrible, it is a joke, it's a horrible joke gone wrong. But ultimately, he's a man caught up in the middle of much, much broader political concerns. Okay, and who will you condemn?
有惊人的文件。是的。这是人们一生中仅此一次的机会。一生仅此一次的机会，是的。把它们放在一起看。好吧，安妮·博林的文件，我的意思是，太棒了。他们需要预订吗？他们需要付钱吗？他们不需要预订。
Somebody has to go. Somebody has to go. I think if you're squeamish, you'd go for Richard III, wouldn't you? Because he's already dead. Richard III has a lot of supporters, and I'm not going to condemn you'll get just endless grief on twitter if you condemn richard i am going to say and steve coogan like a film about you i am going to say guy thorks controversially because i think he's targeting it's such a wide
不。不。这两者都不需要。不，绝对不需要。如果你对叛国罪还是觉得看不够，还有一本与之配套的精彩书籍：《叛国史：通过最臭名昭著的叛徒的故事看英国血腥历史》。多米尼克，我们接下来还有更多臭名昭著的叛徒，对吧？我们热爱叛徒。这只是两集特别节目的第一部分。如果你喜欢听我们谈论羊皮纸和叛徒，那你绝对走运了，因为我们下次会带着更多
it's such a wide attack on the institutions and it it does make that change between from count from crown to state so you could have gone off table and chosen thomas moore you didn't that's fine no i don't think i think the fifth of guy forks is the perfect choice because fifth of november yeah emblematic of gunpowder treason and plot and that is the date on which um this fantastic exhibition at the National Archives is opening. Tom, let me just reiterate. What? There are amazing documents.
这类东西回归，不仅有羊皮纸，我们还将进入19世纪、20世纪、21世纪的叛徒。所以尤恩，非常感谢你。祝贺你举办了这个精彩的展览。致我们的听众，我们下次见。与此同时，希望你们已经去过国家档案馆亲自观看了展览，并且你们会买这本书，这样你们就会比我们了解得更多。但无论如何，我们下次再见。再见！再见！感谢收听《其余皆是历史》。想要获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告收听
Yes. This is people's once-in-a-lifetime opportunity. Once-in-a-lifetime chance, yes. To see them together. Well, the Amberlynn document, I mean, fantastic. And do they have to book? Do they have to pay money? They don't have to book.
抢先收听、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
No. No. Neither of those things. No, absolutely not. And if you simply can't have enough of treason, there is also a fantastic book that goes with it, History of Treason, the bloody history of Britain through the stories of its most notorious traitors. And Dominic, we have more notorious traitors to come, don't we? We love traitors. This is only the first part of a two-part special. If you like us talking about parchments and traitors, you're absolutely in luck because we were back next time with more
我是理查·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《其余皆是娱乐》。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、少量八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及优先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那就是 therestisentertainment.com。这个单集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
of this kind of stuff but not just parchment because we will be moving into the uh the 19th and the 20th the 21st century traitors so ewan thank you so much thank you congratulations on this amazing exhibition to our listeners we'll see you next time in the meantime hopefully you've been to the national archives to see the exhibition for yourselves and you'll report the book so you'll be better informed than we are but either way we will see you next time goodbye bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad free listening Early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community. Please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
这类东西，不仅仅是羊皮纸，因为我们将进入19世纪、20世纪和21世纪的叛国者时期。尤恩，非常感谢你，祝贺你举办了如此精彩的展览。听众朋友们，我们下次再见。同时，希望你们能亲自去国家档案馆参观展览并购买这本书，这样你们就会比我们了解得更多。无论如何，我们下次再见，再见。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》，如需收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你它的运作方式。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家节目和提前购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。